Speaker 1: So last week, we talked about President
Joe Biden's declining approval rating and
it's been a significant decline as of last
week, Joe Biden's approval rating was down
about 16 percent.
Now, that's 16 percent, not 16 points from
about 55 to 46.
My sense last week was that Joe Biden's approval
rating would probably continue down before
it might recover, depending on what happens.
But my sense was we hadn't yet seen the bottom.
The reason that I thought that was that the
full scope of the Afghanistan situation wasn't
yet in last week's polling.
And what I mean by that is that the polling
we looked at early last week was taken mostly
before the suicide attack by ISIS at Kabul
Airport in Afghanistan.
And in fact, I pointed out last week that
Joe Biden's approval decline actually started
in July before any of the Afghanistan situation
got going.
But certainly the Afghanistan situation was
not helping and that we would probably see
a further decline.
Indeed, in the last week, Joe Biden's approval
has exactly as expected, continued to decline
not dramatically more than last week, but
the downward trajectory is clear and he's
now down to just a hair over 45 percent approval.
We care more about the average of polls than
about any individual poll.
We want to look at sort of the general direction.
But there are now some individual polls showing
Joe Biden at only 42 percent and 44 percent
approval and there may be even more of a decline.
So what are the important notes here?
Why is this happening?
What are we looking for?
What do we expect?
Two of the major drags on.
Joe Biden's approval right now are covid resurgence
with Delta four, which really Republican governors
and antiwar anti boxers and anti maskers are
to blame more than Joe Biden's policy.
Biden's policy has been get people vaccinated,
keep schools safe.
But I don't deny that ultimately the buck
stops with Biden and he has said that.
So that's one drag which at a sort of nitty
gritty level is actually the fault of mostly
Republicans.
The second drag is Afghanistan.
So if covid improves by November of twenty
twenty two for the midterms, I believe people
will have forgotten about Afghanistan in general.
Foreign policy impacts voting less than domestic
policy, and Biden himself is not actually
on the ballot.
You can see November of 22 as a sort of referendum
on Joe Biden for sure.
But this may not really be the end of the
world for Joe Biden and Democrats in November
of twenty two.
Now, for a comparison to prior presidents,
Joe Biden's approval today is still seven
points higher than Trump's at this point in
their presidencies.
But below both where Barack Obama was at this
point in his presidency and below were George
W. Bush's approval was at this point in his
presidency.
So what does it mean?
What's next?
Really, there's no change from what we outlined
last week on Afghanistan.
Execution aside, Joe Biden got us out of a
war that we needed to get out of.
That's good.
That's the big story.
The big story is Bush got us into Afghanistan.
Obama didn't get us out.
Trump didn't get us out.
Biden got us out.
Were there execution mistakes?
Of course.
And we've talked about it.
There's no doubt about that.
But I don't believe that the big narrative,
which is Biden got us out and it didn't go
perfectly, is going to impact 2022.
The tough part comes where Biden now really
needs a big success.
But the lower his approval rating, the less
likely that Republicans are going to be incentivized
to work with him unless he makes some gigantic
compromises, for example, on infrastructure,
which might turn Biden's victory into a Pyrrhic
one, a Pyrrhic victory, one in which you sustain
so much damage in getting the victory that
in practice it's a question as to whether
really it's a victory.
So it's this vicious circle.
Biden needs a big accomplishment to Buie,
his approval rating.
But having a lower, lower approval rating
reduces the pressure on Republicans to actually
work with Joe Biden because his approval rating
is already lower.
And the expectations from the American public
that Republicans work with him may also be
diminished.
Joe Biden is expected to address the nation
tomorrow, Thursday, about covid.
There's a question as to whether he will be
announcing new guidelines, new restrictions,
mandates, whatever the case may be.
We will see what kind of an audience that
gets.
We will see if it does anything for his approval.
And I don't know what time that is tomorrow,
but my intention is to cover it live on YouTube,
Twitter and Facebook.
So I hope you will join me.
It's been already kind of previewed by the
Biden administration that there is not going
to be an announcement on.
A federal vaccine mandate tomorrow.
There was some theorizing and theorizing is
even probably too generous a term.
There was some speculation by some on the
right that tomorrow is the day that Biden
announces a vaccine mandate.
And that's it for many of them.
What that means, I don't know.
It sounds violent, but OK.
But the administration has already said that
is not that is not the plan.
And in so many words that this is not their
wording.
This is mine.
But it was made clear that Joe Biden is not
announcing a vaccine mandate tomorrow, but
he will be announcing something and we'll
see what that does and we'll continue to track
his approval rating.